I know that in this next chapter that I
consciously create I want to have more
fun I really want to love the process
yeah I don't want to make it so hard on
myself and be gripping everything so
tight and it's really easy for me to see
it in other people because I know what
it feels like in here I'm working hard
to break the patterns that still hold me
back and the big one that holds me back
is bulldozing it's literally when I
start to feel any level of tension this
is particularly true in my marriage I
feel my like whatever emotion rise I
immediately raise my voice it's how I
assert power in the relationship and I
am so committed to Breaking that pattern
and being a more fun person to be around
and a Kinder person to be around you can
change the negative patterns that I run
in your life the patterns that you think
are impossible to break that have been
with you for life that will be with you
for the rest of your life you can break
them it starts with a decision and if
you don't want to still be in 20 years
living by that same negative pattern
that is holding you back
I think this video will help most of
what we do is subconscious most of what
we do is beneath the surface most of
what we do is
what we've been conditioned to do and
the patterns that we've seen and you
know if you're watching this you're
likely an adult and we've been running
the same pattern programming for a
number of years if not decades and
it can be really difficult to be able to
switch that pattern but I'm going to
give you a formula today that I think
will really help and one that I'm
applying myself as well in my life so
step one
is even just acknowledging that the
pattern exists and that you want to make
a change
what is to happen
what is the negative Loop that's in your
mind what is the thing that you don't
want to still be thinking
in the next year two years five years
ten years what is that thing one of the
things that I'm working on is moving to
a space of great things happen to me I
had a great video coaching session with
Beth hendel
and my big aha moment that came from
there was
I believe in the plan
so whenever I am thinking of something I
make a plan and then I execute the plan
and I do the plan and I follow the plan
and when I don't believe in the plan
then I create a new plan and I believe
in that plan and that's the thing that
gets me going so I'm very plain schedule
calendar oriented that gives me my
security that gives me my identity and
so as long as I have a plan easy peasy
let's go waking up we're making videos
because it's in the plan
but then what happens on the rare days
you know maybe once a month where
I don't believe in the plan anymore I
don't think the plan is good enough to
get to where I want to go
and I can't make a new plan I don't know
what the next plan should be what I have
done so that I don't get lost and
spiraled down into negative thinking
into uh maybe not depression but
anxiety and stress and overwhelm that I
don't know what to do next you ever been
faced with that like I don't know what
to do next
my plan has been my plan see I'm using
the words
just to tell myself
great things happen to me this is what
I've done it's in my coping mechanism
the the way out of the stress and the
anxiety and not knowing what to do next
is me telling myself great things happen
to me
and what Beth challenged me to do
and the big Insight that came from it
was living not in the identity of the
plan but living in the great things
happen to me so now I'm trying to shift
my identity from being the guy who
believes in the plan to being the guy
who believes that great things happen to
me that instead of using great things
happen to me just as a coping mechanism
on my worst days the once a month days
when I really don't believe that I'm I'm
getting closer to my goals or I'm never
going to hit them
and flipping that to being the default
mode that's that's really hard I've I've
was not born the plan guy it took me
decades I'm 42 coming up in May I'm 42
and it took me decades to become the
plan guy you know two decades to become
the planned guy
and now I'm I'm not
getting rid of the planned guy thank you
plan guy you got me here I appreciate
you you know Pat in the back I still
need you please stay with me on this
journey but I want to be the guy who
believes the great things are coming
because at the end of the day all your
great things all your great ideas all
your great breakthroughs usually don't
come as a result of the plan
it's maybe a byproduct of the plan but
not a direct result of the plan because
the plan only is something that you know
exists right now it's it's what I've
talked about making decisions with your
head versus your heart big decision with
your heart it's all with the head the
head only understands the world that
currently exists where your heart can
create something brand new and so I want
to be I want to be in the brand new I
want to create something that hasn't
been done before and so the you can't
plan for something that hasn't been done
before and you need to have some faith
that great things will happen and so
that's a long way of me saying that I am
trying to become
the guy who believes that great things
happen to me as a default state
I believe that when I say that when I
create video and I say that on camera or
when I'm talking I believe that I
believe the great things come to me if I
keep going if I keep making if I keep
sharing if I leave with my heart if I
tap into what I feel is the right thing
to do even if it doesn't make sense I
believe that great things will happen
and I've seen enough of that happen over
my life and career that I believe it and
if you're not quite there yet
just look for some small wins that when
you have help when you have shared when
you have created from the heart you've
gotten some small wins and if you keep
going you can have
slightly bigger ones and medium-sized
ones and then large ones and then
gigantic wins if you just keep going so
how do I shift and we're working through
this in real time I'm not sharing a
story that is you know
it's 20 years old like I sometimes might
do the foundation story so how do I ship
how do I shift from being
the plan guy to the great things will
happen to mikai I think it could be
useful Mini case study for you if
there's something that you want to work
on
that you want to improve at you're tired
of telling yourself a different story
and you want to shift it so here's what
I'm doing first off is trigger words
right so if I say plan that's a trigger
word plan ooh plan here's my plan like
oof plan I said it again not that it's
bad right for years it might be bad it
might be it might be a critical you
telling yourself that you're stupid or
that you can't or it can't it could be
another a trigger word or hard it's
another trigger word the fact that
you're not going to do something because
it's hard that's a trigger word right so
what are the trigger words that you tell
yourself as to why you can't do
something or that keep you locked in
your negative patterns what are those
trigger words that anytime you catch it
you say it you feel it you tell somebody
else it that like oh there it is again
I'm noticing it and you can tell the
people in your life your your family
your friends your spouse people on your
team you can tell them hey if I ever say
this word I want you to I want you to
call me out of it so you can have people
kind of support you through this journey
as well number two is you try to design
in the conscious way
applying it in your life consistently so
the next thing I did as soon as I got
off that coaching call with Beth was I
told Nina I told my wife and I said hey
great things happen to us I told her
what happened and great things happened
to us great things happen to us great
things happen to us and I honestly I
must say that at least 40 times a day
great things happen to me I'm talking to
myself or great things happen to us
if you want you can set it as a alarm in
your phone you could put it as a
background on your on your computer
screen you can put it as a sticky note
on the bathroom mirror or the door I
have a email that I sent myself that I
didn't delete out of my inbox so so I
always see it in my inbox every day when
I'm checking my email I check my email
once a day and it's always the last
email that I that I checked because I
never removed from my inbox and it says
this is your great things happen to
reminders
this is your great things happen you
reminder every time you say oh that's
right great things happen to me because
that's still not it's nowhere close to
being my default but I'm working towards
becoming that person
so it's the decision to do it and then
with intention putting things into your
calendar so that it happens so again
maybe you're setting an alarm on your
phone maybe you're putting the picture
up on your wall you're telling your
friends and the people around you and
you're finding a way to repeat it to
repeat it to repeat it to repeat it and
I'm not judging myself as to I need to
get this done next week
I just want to make a little bit of
progress every day Beth's team reached
out and wanted to do a round two of
coaching and I said I'm still I mean
thank you it's amazing I'm still working
on the last thing you know the great
things happen to me
shift in mindset is something that I'm
working through and
it's incredibly powerful and I don't
think I need any help for anything else
yet I'm still working through this thing
this week has been a really challenging
week for anina and myself as well we are
we ran our build to serve challenge
which which was crazy
um when we first did it the the idea
that was pitched to me was seven days 45
minutes to an hour each day and we ended
up going the seven days and you know
three to four hours each day which I
didn't budget for but it was amazing
helping thought leaders and speakers and
coaches and entrepreneurs authors
just the energy and the vibe and the
love was so amazing that it took up an
incredible amount of time at the same
time we just bought a a brand new house
which is super exciting and so selling
this place and so I had to move my up
you might notice it's a different
background than usual I'm not I guess I
could have done it in my car
um but I'm not in my usual Studio my
office because we have a makeshift
office while we get our place ready to
list today
so we're packing and moving and
switching all the artwork and all of
that stuff while running a challenge uh
yesterday I hit the side of a a curb
that had a rock
not a rock like a boulder and it
punctured my tire and not just like
giant hole in my tire uh so okay we have
to go and get the car fixed on top of
everything else which is why I can't
film in the in the car like I normally
do because I don't have a car right now
because it's being fixed because we I
blew out the tire and just issue over
issue over issue and
my niece was with us yesterday
and she made a comment to my wife Nina
about how calm we were through
everything like okay well the car tire
got blown out uh that's that completely
changes how we spend the rest of today
now instead of doing these errands and
taking people here and all of this stuff
uh on Nina's birthday by the way
it's like okay well here's what we need
to do now you know okay we're gonna get
fixed we gotta figure out how to solve
these other problems and let's go and
she was my niece was blown away but how
we weren't arguing or fighting or
yelling or
uh super stressed just okay let's solve
the problem and keep moving around with
our day why because great things happen
to us
great things happen to us and that's you
know when something negative going on
even if it doesn't feel real
it'll be something that Nina and I will
laugh over great things happen to us oh
that happened okay great great thing you
know what great things happen to us
figure out a way through this great
things happen to us and in that ongoing
conditioning
the more that it's around us the more
that I say it I believe it a little bit
more and a little bit more and a little
bit more and a little bit more and I
guess you could call it affirmations I I
never really
connected to affirmations that much
because it felt
if I was saying something that I didn't
believe in that
that it wouldn't it wouldn't work for me
and because I already believed that it
wouldn't work for me then I've already
set myself up for feeling from the
beginning I think the key thing is if
you want to be able to change that
mindset you want to change the Habit
Loop you have to find something that you
actually on your best days believe
there's a kernel of Truth in there right
if you're 400 pounds and you say I'm
skinny I'm skinny I'm skinny I think I
think a lot of
in your head you say well that's BS I'm
not skinny and and then you don't
there's no even kernel of truth to it so
then you never do the actions to help
you get there where on your best days
when you believe about yourself on your
best days how do you handle problems
so when I say great things happen to me
I believe it
I actually believe that that wasn't
something that was given to me that
wasn't something that somebody once told
me that wasn't somebody that a coach
told me that okay you have to use this
now as your Mantra I believe it on my
best days I believe it I believe it I
can I can tap into that and I believe it
there's a kernel of truth to it and I
want to make that kernel you know grow
into something much much much much
bigger so homework would be to think
about
on your best days what do you believe
about yourself what what's the specific
language the specific words that you
would say to yourself to encourage
yourself or you're looking back and
you're proud of yourself on your best
days what do you believe about yourself
and then finding a way to make that a
daily part of your life
so that when the negative things come
you can tell yourself this as a reminder
and it starts to shift everything for
you
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
when a manager or a boss defines Norms
the team is 73 times more likely to work
hard to keep them and here's the kicker
there are 125 times more likely to
address the situation if there's
somebody on the team who is not
operating within the norms
you know I I it's it's so obvious
somebody were to walk in
to work
and put their feet up on the desk and
turn on porn
and be sitting at their desk watching
porn would that be the norm
for your workplace I don't think so
unless you're working for Playboy or
you're working in the porn industry that
would be so out of the norm that
everybody would address it immediately
period full stop
and what I want you to understand is
that when you take responsibility for
how you're acting on the team and you're
collaborative and you're supportive and
you're putting the team first and you're
modeling that behavior and when you also
bring the courage and you dare as brene
Brown says to be brave enough to have
honest conversations with your
colleagues about what's acceptable and
what's not based on how things are
impacting you you personally shift the
culture in a positive direction
everything that I have done since since
we launched the five second rule book
was in reaction to things that were
coming to me
so I never sat out and said hey the five
second rule audiobook has been a
complete uh like record breaker we
clearly have an audio audience let's go
pitch audible audible came to me which
is fantastic
um I never I always dreamed about having
a talk show but I wasn't out pitching
one
Sony came to me in fact the only reason
why we got into courses online courses
and we now have more than a half a
million people that have taken our
courses online
um
was because Success magazine came to me
and said let's do a course together
remember I was there interviewing you
for it oh and I was I hated it because
what I discovered is I hate being told
what to do and so but that gave me the
idea oh we should do courses ourselves
and so this pause has made me stop and
go what do I really want to do
and the the truth is I want to go and
make the biggest possible impact that I
can and I want to collaborate with more
people yeah and I want to do events
um and I
I don't want to be the CEO I'm a
terrible leader horrible leader the
worst actually
um because I'm amazing at coaching I'm
amazing at uh creating I'm amazing at
reacting I'm terrible at managing people
I am terrible at managing a project I
have ADD I have dyslexia
um I'm a bulldozer when I get anxious
um
we kill each other if we were roommates
or business partners but but I think
understanding yourself
is really important and so there's a
couple things that I've decided number
one I'm going to consciously create the
next check yeah and what is that and I'm
um well I'm still in the middle of doing
it yeah but you're one of the events you
want to do these things you're talking
about yeah yes and I wanna I wanna
collaborate more with a wider audience
of people um and I want to build a brand
bigger than Mel Robbins yep I don't want
it to just be me I want to build a
platform based business that uh reaches
more people because here's the thing
that has got that got me through kind of
the loss of the talk show and the way
that I think about things that I hope
helps
um if you're listening yeah kind of
struggling with something
I believe and I went into the talk show
saying this to myself because there's a
99 chance based on the history of people
that have tried to have a daytime talk
show that was going to fail
and I went in there saying
this I'm not doing this because I expect
to have a successful talk show I'm going
to put a thousand percent into it so
that I have no regrets and I wouldn't
change a thing
but I'm going into this because I know
that there is a skill a person or an
experience I am meant to have
that will help me
for the next chapter that I can't see
coming now here's a trick about
gratitude writing down what you're
grateful for doesn't work unless you do
it this way because if you if I ask you
what you're grateful for everybody says
the same thing I'm grateful to be alive
I'm grateful for my health and I'm
grateful for my family and that's so
generic that you're not retraining your
brain right you've got to add in the
because
I'm grateful for X because and the added
detail will make you change up
what you say and it will also train your
mind in a way that's more detailed so it
actually has a lasting impact on the way
that you view the world here's the thing
about morning routines I think morning
routine Envy is a real thing and I do
believe that a lot of people lie about
their morning routines I think lying
about your morning routine is a real
thing I think pretending you have the
perfect morning routine is a real thing
um I'm
I'm about when I'm home I'm almost 80 in
my morning routine I get it done because
it's super simple right so I mean I
think I need a simple one yes and when
I'm traveling
I almost never get the whole thing done
because there's too many excuses I think
the key to having a morning routine and
morning routines are critical because
how you start your day
has a massive proven impact and how your
day turns out there's one piece of
research that I think is really profound
and this comes from Sean anchor I talked
about this yesterday but I'm going to
tell you
um this too Susie if you consume three
minutes just three minutes of negative
news
of negative television of negative
emails maybe stressful emails from work
or stressful texts from friends you have
more than a 50 chance eight hours later
to say you had a bad day
and the reason why is because of what
consuming that kind of information does
to your mind it literally sets your mind
up to be on the lookout for things going
wrong and so the reason why a morning
routine is is actually so important is
because number one it determines what
your priority for the day is and we also
know based on Research that you're lewd
in the morning it impacts your
productivity all day long just because
you identify and for me as a kid for
whatever reason I have my own version of
feeling invisible and feeling like I'm
not good enough and so my way of coping
both with my anxiety and being a
survivor of sexual abuse and
um
and wanting love which we all need is I
was like an overachiever and so I'm the
kind of person that's super busy and a
go-getter because it got me attention
and if I was the one that was super busy
and achieving I not only got praise but
it also insulates you from other people
not picking you because you're the one
in a leadership role doing the picking
right and so there's a part of me at the
age of 51 that is realizing that you
know this these feelings of feeling
unworthy and this hyper drive to try to
achieve it's all coming from a place of
feeling inadequate or like what I'm
doing is not enough and so that's at 50
having a talk show having a best-selling
book having the audible Originals having
the platform everywhere having the
impact is still don't feel being the
most booked female speaker in the world
like you still don't feel so stupid it's
annoying and human beings are annoying
we are stuck with this wiring like if
you think about it like all of the crap
you believe is probably a hangover from
age zero to ten
that as adults we walk around thinking
the same stuff we thought as kids and I
can't stand that I feel that way but
knowing it it allows me to catch it
before it has me before it stops me from
having an event or writing that next
book or taking a risk if you took money
off the table if you didn't give a
what anybody else thought what's the
thing you would love to be doing with
your life seriously do you dream of
being a professional photographer do you
want to open your own restaurant you
always thought about traveling the world
and entertaining kids with uh your
juggling skills I don't know it's your
life you get to choose what you want to
do
be honest with yourself what is it that
you would want to do with your life if
you didn't have to pay the bills doing
it another thing you can ask yourself
who do you find yourself sort of envious
of you know like you look at their life
and you just think gosh how awesome that
they get to do that well once you have
that answer for yourself you've gotten
really honest you've pushed the
aside and you've really asked it for
yourself and answered the question
honestly all you got to do is explore it
that's it just find one thing that you
can do to enrich and expand your
knowledge about it find one course
online Google the topic stalk people
that are pursuing this line of work
that's how you start to do it one step
at a time so start with answering the
question what do you really want with a
massive dose of honesty Google the topic
and find one thing that you can do just
one push yourself and start to explore
if you were to wake up and do that every
single day spend 10 minutes a day you
would be startled astonished by what
your life looks like in a matter of a
year or two I need a volunteer coming up
hi how scared are you right now
12 or 15 or 30. on a scale of 10 yes
good you're perfect okay so I have an
envelope
you can either open this up and read
what it says
but you have to do it
how afraid are you for her
or you can give it to somebody
else
now what are you managing right now my
heart rate is just like out there yeah
what do you want to do life's about
change so I'll open it okay
[Applause]
come up on stage with Mel give her a
standing ovation she deserves it
so again same rules open it up read it
to the audience and then do what it says
how scared are you I'm a little nervous
because I'm not sure what you're going
to want me to do
I'm shy really
that's baloney tell everyone in the
most embarrassing thing that's ever
happened to you all right you ready for
another one sure how scared are you less
she'll be speaking at the next
conference you watch
will
congrats life stats just paying for your
registration and three night hotels stay
at the Elite Academy Orlando
I'm not kidding
[Applause]
it's overwhelmed Joy
um just the piece they think that can
come with really choosing to change you
know I've heard a lot of experts say
that fear isn't real
that is such a bunch of baloney
fear is so real in fact there are
probably things that you're afraid of
doing right now in your life in your
relationships at work and the fact that
you're afraid that's robbing you of all
of the experiences that you want to have
in your life I mean if you're afraid to
fly that's going to limit your ability
to travel and see the world or go visit
friends if you're afraid of public
speaking that's gonna really limit your
ability to express yourself and share
your ideas if you're afraid of talking
to your boss or asking for a raise that
directly impacts how much money you make
or what if you are dreaming of starting
a business or you've already started a
new business but you're afraid to talk
to people and you're afraid to share
your business with people I mean fear is
something that stops us all
and that's why I'm here to talk to you
because it doesn't have to
fear is real but I am going to share a
secret weapon that I have used for years
to beat every single fear that used to
stop me
now first before we get into this secret
weapon I just want to cover a few facts
about fear What It Is What It Isn't and
some things that you may not know about
fear so first thing
fear is a physical state in your body
that is exactly the same as excitement
let me say that again fear and
excitement are the exact same physical
state your heart races you might sweat a
little bit you might feel tightening in
your chest you might feel a pit in your
stomach you have a surge of cortisol
it's basically the way that your body
goes into a hyper aware State because
it's readying for Action Now what's the
difference between fear and excitement
really simple the only difference
between fear and excitement is what your
brain is doing as your body is all
agitated if you're excited your brain's
going oh wow wow this is going to be so
cool to ride this roller coaster
if you're afraid your brain's going oh
no way there's no way I'm doing that
this is dangerous get out of there don't
do that it's saying something different
so what's critical about understanding
this is that we're going to use the fact
that your mind is either working for you
for excitement or against you with fear
to your advantage and I'll tell you
about it in just a minute how you're
going to do that
second thing I want you to understand is
that you may have heard the advice Feel
the fear and do it anyway
you may have heard the advice oh just
try to calm down think positive thoughts
it doesn't work does it and there's a
reason why it doesn't work so let's go
back to fact number one when you're
afraid your body's in a state of arousal
and agitation and your heart is racing
and you're all like amped up and you're
hyper aware of what's going on and
you're freaking out a little bit
what is it like when you're calm
it's just kind of chill right you got
like this low arousal state
very very difficult to go from a state
of agitation and being all jacked up and
excited and weirded out to ah kind of
state
it doesn't work it's like trying to stop
a train by throwing a boulder on the
tracks it's going to make the train jump
off the tracks it's going to cause a
disaster in fact they've proven in
research that when you try to ignore
your fears it actually makes them worse
they've also proven in research that
positive thinking alone also can make
your fears work worse so what do you do
what do you do when you're about to go
talk to your boss and you feel afraid
what do you do when you have to get on a
plane and you're actually terrified of
flying what do you do if you got to give
a presentation and you are afraid of
public speaking here's what you're going
to do you're going to use a strategy the
same one that I use that has helped me
beat every single fear and turned me
into somebody that is terrific when it
comes to a high stress situation this is
how you do it you're going to use my
five second rule in combination with
what I call an anchor thought
and that is going to reframe
what your mind is doing so that your
mind goes from feeling agitation and
making you afraid to reframing it from
agitation to excitement it works like
magic now I have used this technique for
years literally for years and one of the
ways that I want to introduce you to it
is I want to take you backstage
I want to take you backstage to a speech
that I delivered this year and what
you're going to see is you're going to
see me behind you know the major set I'm
about to walk out you can kind of hear
the crowd roaring my introductory video
is playing my body is in a state of
arousal I am literally my heart is
racing my arms are sweating like it's
like you're going to see this I'm going
to tell you about it and you're going to
watch me use this same technique I'm
going to teach you to reframe my nerves
into excitement check this out all right
I'm about to go on stage there are 7 000
people out there and it's so exciting
because what they don't know is they're
about to learn the five second rule and
their lives will never be the same again
now I gotta tell you my heart is racing
um my armpits are sweating
I have the exact same physiological
feeling is when I'm afraid but I'm not
afraid I'm excited excitement and fear
is the exact same thing in your body
it's just what your brain calls it
here's a trick that's proven by science
that I use every time I speak when I
start to sweat when I start to have
butterflies when I start to have my
heart race I say I'm excited I'm excited
to get out there I'm excited to talk to
these people I'm excited to share the
five second rule and what that does is
it sends a message to my brain that
tells my brain why my body's all
agitated and excited and that way I
don't feel afraid remember excitement
and fear exact same thing in your body
the only difference is what your brain
calls
go get him now I want to give you one
more example just to make sure that you
really get how you can use this so a lot
of you have written to me about your
fear of flying and I can really relate
to that fear because I used to have the
exact same fear but I use this same
strategy to conquer it here's how you're
going to do it so first things first if
you've got to do something that really
makes you nervous or that you're afraid
to do before you're about to do it come
up with an anchor thought what's an
anchor thought well an anchor thought is
something that's going to Anchor you so
that you don't escalate any situation
into a full-blown panic attack or into a
situation where you screw things up it's
a way for you to Anchor yourself so you
maintain control over what you're
thinking and how you behave so here's an
example with flying it's important when
you're creating an anchor thought to
pick something that is in the proper
context of what you're afraid to do so
for flying pick an anchor thought that
has to do with the trip that you're
taking so if I'm boarding a plane to fly
back home to Michigan an anchor thought
might be a picture in my mind of my mom
and I walking on the shores of Lake
Michigan where I grew up that's a
thought that makes me happy it makes me
excited and it's also related to the
trip that I'm taking if you have a
conversation that you need to have with
your boss pick an anchor thought about
how you feel after having that
conversation maybe it's you picking up
the phone and calling somebody that you
you love and saying oh my gosh it went
so well or you know you walking out of
the meeting and feeling like yeah I
survived that conversation I feel pretty
good about myself so now that you have
your anchor thought you're ready to beat
the fear what is the biggest obstacle
that we Face
Thiago it's simple it's self-doubt it's
not fear it's not lack of money it's not
lack of supporters it's the fact that
deep down inside
you will doubt yourself at critical
moments and here's the problem with
self-doubt self-doubt doesn't have to
stop you
problem with self-doubt is that the
second that you
feel a little doubtful the second that
you start to question yourself
quickly hesitate
that hesitation has become a habit that
stops you because the moment you
hesitate it wakes up your brain your
brain starts thinking and then you hold
yourself back
you guys know I talk about the five
second rule incessantly it's the title
of the new book that I'm writing that's
coming out in 2017. the five second rule
is a tool that battles self-doubt
because in those moments those those
tiny micro moments when you're faced
with should I do this or should I not
should I speak in a meeting should I
hold back my ideas should I have this
tough conversation or should I wait till
later the second you doubt
option of moving forward
you hesitate then you think then you
hold back that's how it happens every
single time that's how you sabotage your
success that's how you rob yourself Joy
that habit
of hesitating the moment that you feel
now is killing your dreams the single
biggest obstacle in life Thiago
that you feel and the single biggest
mistake that you're making is that you
hesitate when you feel it if you start
to use the five second rule in those
moments to just physically move forward
within five seconds
feeling that doubt
you'll win the talk show experience
was almost like it's it's weird it
almost feels like it didn't happen
really
yeah it was your whole life for like two
years
yeah but you know 175 shows it was in
Super intense
you know it was it was almost a
spiritual experience because
I had dreamed about it for as long as I
could remember
and I stepped onto that talk show set
with such a level of mastery
and the reason why
I had a level of Mastery is because I
could look backwards at my life
and see that I had been
heading to that moment for my entire
life
that the ability to create trust and
take a complicated amount of information
and
get down to the human connection
immediately that began back in 1994 when
I was a legal aid attorney doing
criminal defense work in New York City
my ability to understand what victims of
domestic violence go through uh goes all
the way back to
1986 through 1988 when I was a crisis
intervention counselor volunteering on a
domestic violence hotline my ability to
read a teleprompter had to do with being
at CNN my ability to work 18-hour days
was a function of the reality TV show
world my ability to relate to somebody
who had lost everything was a function
of what Chris and I had gone through my
ability like just everything all of a
sudden was like
and it's why I can say with such urgency
that you have to have faith that this is
happening for a reason that this is
leading somewhere I'm going to take
everybody back four years ago so this is
the first book the high five habit is
the first book that I have written and
published in almost five years
back in 2007 I released a book called
the five second rule and Lisa and her
husband Tom played a pivotal role in one
of the biggest professional breakdowns
of my life and they had no idea that it
was happening at the time no clue and
Lisa I think you just found out about it
by reading about it in chapter 12 of my
new book yep so here's what was going on
I had written the five second rule book
I had self-published it because I
thought that
um that was the best thing to do I had a
dream of being a number one New York
Times best-selling author and I put it
up on my vision board and I dreamed
about it and I thought about it and I
studied all the authors that we all
admire and I did my best to do all the
things that you uh are supposed to do in
order to sell enough books to Grace the
New York Times bestseller list right so
I email my newsletter list and I am do
doing speeches all over the place and
I'm pre-selling books as best I can in
the back of a room with my pad of paper
taking people's like literally for
months I did everything I could
and when the book came out
I sent the email out to everybody
and folks on my email list and everybody
I'm related to immediately went to
Amazon to buy the book
and here's what happened within an hour
or two the book was listed as out of
stock now I thought yes yes
I have won I am a best-selling author I
have sold out of Amazon in a matter of a
few hours oh my God oh my God this like
literally this this proves all the
things that everybody said about me in
middle school is not true anymore I I've
done it Lisa and then I started to
realize I had not sold all the books
because I did not have I had twenty
thousand books at Amazon I did not have
that many people on my email list and
people started to email back going it's
out of stock it's out of stock you think
you'll dream like the height of your
freaking dreams come true yes I think
I've done it like I've sold like I am a
success I am a phenomenon this is
unbelievable I think the dreams are
coming true and then within a couple
hours people start emailing going it's
out of stock now it's out of stock it's
out of stock it's out of stock
it Dawns on me there's no way I sold 20
000 books there's no way
I call the printer that I worked with
that helped me self-publish and you know
it's a little self-publishing publisher
and he tells me that he's seen this
happen before where when Amazon gets a
flood of traffic to something that
they're not expecting
they will turn off Supply
to make sure it's not a bunch of bots
and to also check inventory
and we had no ability
to figure this out so for the first
couple weeks that the book was available
it was out of stock
so here I am
in this two-week period
where I have worked my ass off I have
done everything you're supposed to do
Lisa and my book is out of stock
I have sent my entire marketing campaign
to a product you can't get and I'm
thinking why are you doing this to me
Universe I have worked hard why do I
have to be the bad news bearers why am I
not part of that super like awesome
group of best-selling authors one is it
going to be my turn and I start to go
down the drain
enter
Tom and Lisa Villa so when I come here
and I am doing your show
I show up here and I'm like this is my
last hope Because by the time this thing
gets on air maybe the book will be
available I have got to pull myself
together so I walk in here and I was
just I I didn't know you yet because I
only knew like impact Theory and I've
only seen it I knew this was a big deal
I knew that being on Tom's show could
really like change things for me and I
walk in here and I feel like a complete
failure you are lovely and delightful
and I immediately start feeling like I
don't freaking belong here I mean they
just had this best-selling author and
that best-selling offer and this famous
person was just here what am I doing
here I am a self-published author with a
book that's out of stock like I'm I'm
failing I hope that they don't know
because this is terrible like he is
going to figure out before I enter the
set that I don't belong here you think
imposter syndrome Galore oh completely
so I'm upstairs in the bathroom and I am
having a case no kidding a stress
diarrhea like I have got to empty the
bowels because I am so sure that I'm
about to be called out for the fraud
that I am that the book is not
successful that Tom's made a mistake I
look at the mirror my cheeks are as red
as a baboon's ass I am sweating
profusely I've got pit stains on my red
shirt and then there's a knock on the
door we're ready for you Mel
I splash water on my face
I literally am like
five four three two one like pull your
together Mel get the out there
and I open up the door and I go and one
of the things that you believe that I
believe too is that your feelings are
gonna rise and they're gonna fall
and feeling nervous and feeling scared
and feeling on edge and imposter
syndrome it's all normal stuff you gotta
develop the ability to feel all that
stuff have your cheeks be as red as a
baboon's butt and walk out there and do
it anyway
that's what you've got to develop in
life and that moment taught me that and
there was something else that happened
so when I left that set
the whole time that the book was out of
stock and I'm sitting here going woe is
me and I failed again and I screw
everything up and why doesn't anything
ever work out for me I would catch
myself
and I would say this there's no way Mel
that you've worked this hard
that something amazing isn't going to
happen
you have to keep going you have to
believe that this moment is preparing
you for something amazing that hasn't
happened yet I have been practicing this
habit for a little over a year
and it all began in April of 2020 and
this is not something that I was like
okay I gotta write a book It's gotta
have a five in it it's going to be five
years since I've written a book Thank
You dyslexia and ADHD what am I going to
write about what am I that that's not
how this happened the high five habit
saved me it was a ladder that helped me
climb out of a hole I had fallen into
emotionally
physically spiritually and a year later
after practicing what is going to sound
like a weird
stupid thing which you will resist and
Jay you and I are going to unpack this
because it's sad why everybody resists
it it has to do with the dust that's
accumulated
and I will tell you after a year of
practicing this
I don't even see
a face or a body
I see a soul I don't even have to
high-five myself I still do because it
feels good and we're going to explain
the science that is bananas about why
this actually works for everybody who
tries it because this is not something
that's new
you are tapping into programming that's
already in your mind and body and now
directing it back at yourself it's
incredible
I don't ever criticize myself
I don't ever see what's wrong I see a
human being who's trying who deserves
love and respect and I know that it's my
job to give it to her
you know the five second rule which I
created I don't know over a decade ago
that's gone on to help me change my
whole life it's a little starting ritual
and a brain hack that you can use to
help yourself take the actions and
change the thoughts that change your
life
it helped me be more productive it
helped me get stuff done
the high five habit has changed who I am
it has deleted a lifetime of criticism
and negativity from my mind and it has
reprogrammed the soundtrack to be
somebody that's supportive and a
cheerleader it's extraordinary my brand
of self-help is Mel's life is kind of
up at the moment and she can't
figure out how to help herself so she
stumbles by accident on something really
stupid on its face
and it feels good and then I share it
with my audience and if they pick up on
it and they then I'm like okay we're on
to something so for me the high five Tom
began I'm fired from my talk show my
book contract is canceled every speech
has been canceled my kids are now home
so we've got three kids 20 to 20 uh age
15 all in varying states of distress I
am triggered because my origin story as
you know from being on the show and us
being friends the five second rule was
12 years ago losing everything and so
I'm now having this feeling like I'm
about to lose everything and I'm also
feeling like I'm losing grip on reality
as the pandemic is hitting and as my
kids are in distress and I don't know
what to do just like everybody on the
planet I find myself in my bathroom one
morning in my underwear and I am having
this spiral of negative thoughts I look
like
I don't know how to fix this
I wish somebody would solve this for me
I feel overwhelmed I feel scared about
my parents health I feel scared about
everybody on the front lines
and even though I'm literally like you
somebody that empowers other people I
didn't know what the to say to
myself
and as pathetic as it sounds I found
myself just raising my hand just in a
way to basically be like
shut up Mel come on girl you like put
your shoulders back lift your CH you you
got this you can do this
and something shifted and I went on with
my day and then the next morning I walk
into my bathroom and this is the other
weird thing about the high five I've
literally either criticized myself or
ignored myself in the mirror for decades
when you start to have a moment with
yourself
the crazy part is you start to build a
partnership with yourself that's
interesting like you know when you are
pulling out of your driveway or you're
walking down the street you see a
neighbor and they greet you
you will start to have that experience
when you create this intentional moment
with yourself in the mirror every
morning
and so as I started to do this I thought
this is actually making me feel like the
wind is at my back when I leave the
bathroom it's making me feel just like
when you leave a huddle in sports and
you high five or you're a runner running
a race or doing some big endurance
Challenge and some spectator high fives
you or another Racer's like come on you
got this as you're dragging down low
it gives you a little energy like I
think too about this high five a lot
like I know we're you know you're
friends with David Goggins I'm a huge
fan of Goggins and so and I know there's
a lot of people that watch this show
especially men that are like this sounds
kind of stupid this is the equivalent of
Goggins cookie jar moment so we all
think like we've all been raised like
tough love hard on myself
bullsh the research is clear on this
being hard on yourself is not motivating
it's demotivating
and if you already feel like a failure
or you feel a sense of shame or you're
overwhelmed beating yourself up for
where you are doesn't work it drives you
into the gutter the most motivating
force in the world on the planet based
on Research hands down is empowerment
encouragement support and celebration
and for our entire lives we have
outsourced that to somebody else
the research is very clear so the NBA
study they did this big study looking at
NBA teams and they could predict in the
study who was going to be in the
championship rounds based on in the
preseason what teams had the most high
fives fist bumps and backpaths why
because those kind of gestures create
partnership and trust and I'm here to
tell you when you start doing it in the
mirror you're creating partnership and
trust with yourself so the holidays are
upon us and I wanted to share my three
rules around the holidays to make sure
that even if you have a very
dysfunctional family you can focus on
the fun in Dysfunctional okay so here
are my three rules and they're all like
the three p's of the holidays okay so
you can think about holiday dinner you
don't like to eat your peas these are
the peas that you want to focus on you
ready number one no politics seriously
do not utter anything about anything
related to politics we live in a crazy
polarized whacked out time right now
when it comes to politics there is no
safe topic even if everybody voted for
the same people do not discuss it that
that's rule number one no Politics the
second P leave the past in the past do
not dance into Thanksgiving dinner or
any holiday that you're celebrating
during this long season and expect it to
be the moment in time that you're going
to resolve everything that's happened to
you in your past that belongs in a
therapy session or during a long walk in
the woods when you're actually focused
on healing in the past for now you just
want to get along with everybody you
want to have a fun time you don't want
to make this too heavy and you do not
want to be the one bringing the drama to
the table leave that to one of your
uncles or your aunts okay and number
three pretend you care okay no politics
don't heal the past pretend you care
it's not that difficult you don't have
to love everybody you don't have to like
everybody but show up and actually
demonstrate behavior that makes people
feel as if you care what does that mean
it means ask a lot of questions listen
follow up with more questions and you
know the great thing about asking lots
of questions of the folks that are there
at the holidays with you number one it
takes the focus off of you so if you're
worried about talking about where you
are or you aren't in your life ask a lot
of questions you won't be talking about
yourself at all and number two when
other people are talking they think
you're very interesting that's true the
secret to human beings is be interested
because when you're interested in
everybody else suddenly you're the most
interesting person in the room while
they're talking for those of you that
feel very overwhelmed because of
homework side hustle and you're a woman
you probably also feel guilty about
taking time to work on your side hustle
that's because women women girls we are
raised to be good girls we're raised to
be good daughters we're raised to not be
seen and not heard or raised to take
care of people it's socialized into you
and you see your mothers by the way also
sacrifice everything to take care of
everybody else and to put themselves up
this is a learned behavior so if you
also are a woman you probably feel
guilty for taking time for yourself stop
that you have to stop that
the reason why you have to stop that is
first of all if your mom you've got to
show your daughters and your sons what
it looks like to pursue your dreams
secondly as a woman you're not going to
get what you want if you're constantly
putting guilt on yourself for taking
time for yourself and third the only way
you will discover the power and
potential inside of you is if you push
that generational to the side
and you actually realize that your life
is for you that your mom you know why
she sacrificed everything she did
because she wanted you to pursue your
dreams so knock it off with the guilt
because the guilt is also contributing
to the overwhelm the guilt is making you
not talk to your partner or your boss or
your colleagues or your friends about
what you need for support the guilt is
time and be disciplined to find the time
for yourself and so it has got to go you
hear me get rid of it rule number eight
change your story isn't it interesting
that age is something that measures the
amount of time that's gone by but don't
you have a lot of baggage about your age
you're either too young or you're too
old or too much time has passed or you
blew it and you wasted your 30s or now
that you're 40 or this or you're only
20. I mean it's insane how much baggage
we all have about our age and so I'm
writing about how to
remove that story and how to recognize
that whatever time has passed has passed
whether it's a teeny amount of time
because you're just a high school
student or it's a lot of amount of time
because you're 60 years old and to
understand that life is an inside game
and it's all about your mindset and it's
all about what you do with the time that
you have right now you can launch
anything you can begin anything period
as long as you are willing to do the
work for it if you're somebody that
suffers from anxiety first of all here's
what you need to know it's not a disease
period it's not a disease here's what
you need to understand
anxiety always begins with a worry
always
it begins with a thought that is
triggered by something so if you suffer
from anxiety you wake up in the morning
and your mind spins you lay in bed at
night and your mind spins you walk into
work and you feel anxious in your body I
want you to write down all the things
that trigger you to feel anxious
interestingly another major trigger is
being home or going home and that moment
right before your partner walks in the
door
if you feel anxious when your partner's
about to walk in or you're about to walk
into your own home that is a major
signal that you're in the wrong
relationship that there is something
incredibly off and you either need to
get into counseling but that is one that
we hear a lot about wow
um because you're walking into a
situation that feels uncertain yeah a
lot of people by the way had parents
that were abusive or parents that were
yellers so they also are experiencing
ghosts from the childhood of its five
o'clock dad's about to come home and
pour a drink and everybody's on edge
yeah so write down the triggers okay
because having having kind of the
triggers ahead of time will help you
come up with a plan for how you're going
to catch yourself when your mind
defaults to the automatic ways that it
thinks then what I want you to write
down next to the trigger is what exactly
are you worried about
so having the trigger and then the what
do I worry about I worry that my boss is
going to yell I worry that my partner's
going to yell I worry that I'm going to
get in trouble I worry that
um you know my friends are gonna laugh
at me I worry that I'm going to be a
whatever the it may be then what
you're going to do is you're going to
write down what I call an anchor thought
an anchor thought is something that
weighs you down and it makes you excited
and so here's how the strategy works
with the five second rule the next time
you're in a situation and let's just use
the example of pulling into your own
driveway or your own apartment and maybe
you've got issues with your boyfriend or
girlfriend or your roommate and that
makes you unsettled you're the second
you pull in and you feel the trigger
You're Gonna Go five four three two one
because I want to interrupt your mind
from going into the I don't like
what if and then you're going to drop in
the anchor thought of the last time that
you and your roommate really got along
well
or the last time that you stood up for
yourself and it went fine and you're a
puppy yeah or a puppy or whatever you're
gonna say I'm so excited
to deal with this yeah and then you're
going to get out of your car even though
your body is going to feel a little
unsettled and your mind's gonna raise go
54321 if you start to like be like uh
but whatever
[Music]
and then walk in the door
and what I'm teaching you to do is to
not let your mind hijack you right and
it's very important because there's a
very tight Nexus between
your habit of worrying and spiraling
your thoughts and the way your body
starts to amp up and so we want to
settle your mind so we don't agitate
your body you got it yeah and so if you
start to practice that over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again and for you 18 year olds that are
watching this use this with the nerves
that you have about what you're going to
do with your life use this when you
catch yourself worrying about college
applications because worrying about the
applications won't get them done
worrying about what your friends are
doing won't make it happen worrying
about what you're going to be doing when
you're 25 or how you're going to make
money it's not going to help you make
money right now it's only going to make
you miserable so 54321 cut off that
habit yeah
that'll stabilize your body and then go
to a vision of you at the age of 25
driving a car that you think is cool and
hanging out with a friend that's cool
and saying to yourself I'm so excited
because I know I'm going to figure it
out
because you don't need to worry about
that right now yeah but it becomes
a habit that destroys your year this
year I've looked into the research
there's only one habit and skill just
one that has a direct impact on how much
money you make a direct impact on
whether or not you get the promotion and
the influence and the cash money that
you deserve and do you know what that is
any ideas
the one skill the one habit the one
thing that has a meaningful Behavior
change that impacts
what you get
it's your visibility you see you don't
get credit you don't get paid for it and
you don't get graded on the things that
people can't see in order for you to get
what you deserve you have to start being
deliberate about your visibility
behavior that you've got to start
learning to do whether you're shy
whether you're introverted whether
English is your second language it
doesn't matter you've got to learn how
to speak up you've got to learn how to
share your ideas you've got to learn how
to talk about your business you've got
to learn to talk about your dreams and
your goals and I know for many of you
that is one of the most terrifying
things in the world you hate being the
center of attention the idea of speaking
in a meeting at work and risking
sounding like you don't know what you're
talking about is really scary the idea
of asking for feedback from your boss or
asking for a raise really scary the idea
of going in and talking to your
professor about adjusting your grade
really scary the idea of raising your
hand I get it I read your emails I see
the comments but you've got to
understand that this is the number one
skill that you need in order to increase
your visibility wherever it is that you
need to increase your visibility there's
a lot of you that are running from
things
instead of running two things
and that's a huge difference running
from something versus running to
something and so I want you to think
about that for a minute
um because you don't have to move across
country to change your life
and you don't have to do something
drastic to experience drastic positive
change
and here's the thing about running away
from your problems running away from
your past have you ever noticed that
when you run away
it tends to follow you
you know I used to have this problem in
relationships and the reason why I had
this problem is because I was a very
unhappy person
I didn't like myself truly as a person
until probably four or five years ago I
spent as sad as this is I spent the
first 46 years of my life really not
liking myself really
um feeling like I wasn't a good person
really questioning the sanity of people
that were in love with me or that were
friends of mine because I had such a low
opinion of myself and it didn't matter
you know I I was guilty not of moving
from one city to another
but I was guilty of moving from one
person to another that I would literally
get in a relationship I would be in a
relationship for a year and then I would
start to feel that unsettled feeling
because what happens after a year of
being in a relationship well you got to
start working on it it's no longer the
thrill and the delight and it's new and
you're dating now it's just you and the
person in your life
there's nothing new about it and so all
your old crap starts to show up and
that's when you got to start to do the
work and so it was about the year or the
year and a half mark in almost every
single relationship that I would start
getting that itchy feeling and the
reason why I was getting that itchy
feeling is because my past was now there
this new relationship was no longer new
and so I was no longer distracted by it
and I was going to have to deal with
myself in order to be happy and so what
did I do for years not even just years
decades everybody I'm not I'm not proud
to admit this but I would literally jump
out of one relationship and into another
new one because another new one would
distract me from the fact that I was an
unhappy person
true story and I think a lot of you who
are unhappy with yourselves are looking
to move jobs or looking to move uh the
city that you live in or you're looking
to change your relationship and the
problem isn't where you live the problem
isn't your job the problem isn't the
person that you're with the problem is
how you feel about yourself if you're
not facing a breakup personally in your
romantic life you still want to pay
attention because somebody that you care
about might be and this is advice that
you can give to them also breakups uh
happen in your career
um you might be breaking up with a work
situation you might be breaking up with
a friend I know a lot of us are working
hard to draw boundaries and to surround
ourselves with more positive people and
we get questions every day about how you
do that and so breaking up with friends
can be just as traumatic as breaking up
with somebody that is a romantic partner
I have three steps to getting over for a
breakup that I'm going to explain in a
minute but first I want to under I want
to explain some research to you to help
you put what you're feeling into context
because what you're going through when
you break up with somebody or you're
broken up with is you literally go
through withdrawal I'm not kidding and
yeah I'm using the word withdrawal where
else do you hear the word withdrawal you
hear the word withdrawal when you hear
about people withdrawing from a drug and
that's a lot uh similar to what you're
going through in fact there was a study
done by neuroscientist Lucy Brown who
found that like drug abuse romantic love
begins with that euphoric feeling it's a
high right and when the drug leaves your
body or the romance leaves your life
what are you left with you're left with
the withdrawal which is a craving for it
validate number one
breakups are painful but they don't need
to lead you broken so I want you to
validate where you're at it's great that
you're asking the question you got to
have a little bit of compassion for
yourself you got to understand that
you're going to be sad for a while but
please don't pour gasoline on the
sadness fire please please please don't
be staring at photos of your ex please
don't be uh putting his or her social
media face right in front of your face
it's gonna make it worse but definitely
validate the sadness because you're
going through a major change and it
might not be a change that you wanted
number two separate this is the most
important part because the other thing
that I don't think any of us realize is
that when you get broken off with or you
break up with somebody
you don't realize how much of your daily
routine and the habits that you have and
the way that you go about your day was
tied to the person that you're no longer
with and so what you're not only dealing
with is not only missing the person but
your whole life schedule may have just
been thrown off maybe you two went to
the same gym in the morning maybe you
got a text in the morning from this
person maybe you liked your little
FaceTime call at work maybe your friend
group became their friend group and now
all of a sudden that you're broken up
because you hung out with their friends
all the time you don't have that social
life anymore and so it is so important
for you to recognize that you're not
only facing the person being gone but
the habits that marked your day and the
other people that maybe you hung out
with and the things that you did with
your time and the music that you listen
to and the food that you ate that those
might have all been dictated by the
person you were with and those are
changing too so it's important for you
to separate yourself I think a lot of
women in particular when we get into a
relationship we tend to lose ourselves
we tend to morph into the person that
we're dating I used to do that all the
time and so now we get to the third part
as you start to think about separating
right so you're validating where you're
at you're separating from this person we
need to get to the third part which is
celebrating you
now that you're broken up you have an
opportunity you have an opportunity to
ReDiscover yourself because I guarantee
you you lost a bit of yourself in that
relationship and so as you think about
the way that the structure of your day
has changed what can you proactively
insert that is a celebration of the
things that you stop doing
what have you been keeping yourself from
doing because you are in this
relationship that would celebrate you
who are the friends or family members or
colleagues that really lift you up and
how can you find more time to hang out
with them this is a time to celebrate a
moment when you get to ReDiscover you
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want another amazing Mel Robbins video
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there